so many opportunities to implement his
uh wonderful way. Alhamdulillah.
Now the next question of great
importance again is um when it comes to
the fast
is it simply the doing away of food,
drink and sexual relations or other
implications?
The things which are further for a
person who fasts as we mentioned
earlier. One of them is to abstain from
things that break the fast that is food,
drink and having sexual relationship.
But besides this one another important
factor is is the intention is the nia.
Any deed without the nia
for the akra it is useless. The nia
should be there. The ny the intention is
very important because we intend to fast
to please Allah subhanaa tala it's act
of worship if this intention is not
there then there are various different
types of fast for example a person may
fast for political reason a person may
fast as a passive resistance a person
may fast as hunger strike I'm starving
hunger strike to get whatever he wants
you know there are people fasting
non-Muslims
A person may fast for health reason
maybe for dieting. He may fast maybe to
lose weight. He may fast it may be a
medical treatment. But all these fasts
they do not have intention the nia to
please Allah subhanaa tala. So that is
the reason in the Islamic Sharia when we
abstain from things that break the fast
it should be accompanied by the nya.
Without the nia the fast is useless.
It's very important. Nia is compulsory
for every act of worship including
fasting and our beloved prophet wasallam
said it's mentioned in say Muslim volume
number two in the book of zakat chapter
number 370 had number 2198 our beloved
prophet said that when you have
intention
to approach your wife to have
relationship with your wife the moment
you have intention even that becomes
charity. The Sahabas asked having
relationship with your wife is also
charity how come oh beloved prophet but
the prophet said that if you have sexual
relationship with people who are not
your wives if it's unlawful isn't it a
sin they said yeahool Allah yes it is a
sin so that is if you have sexual
relationship with the person you're
supposed to have that is your wife with
the nia that's an act of charity that
means nia is very important the moment
you have nia Huh? Then you get sab for
that. And Allah says in the Quran in
surah chapter number 98 verse number 5
it's mentioned and he commanded that you
worship him alone and in sincere
devotion true in faith. Here the word
used is leabu which means to worship.
But actually abu it means to humble. But
the word leabudu in Arabic is normally
used for worship. It actually means to
humble. The other Arabic word used is
mlum which means to serve with piety and
with dedication.
So here we should serve only for Allah
and a worship should be to him alone.
That should be a that is the intention.
And Allah says in the Quran in surah
bakar chapter number two verse number 29
that we have created for you everything
on this earth. When Allah has created
everything in this earth for us not
one10enth not 1/5th not 1/4 not half but
everything for the human beings in this
earth. So but natural our servitude
should only be to him and no one else.
If while worshiping him we worship
somebody else then it is useless. We
have to only worship him and no one
else. We can't say that I am praying two
raat for Allah and two raat for somebody
else. We can't say that I'm sacrificing
one goat for Allah and the second goat
for a king or a ruler. All our worship
should be to him alone and no one else.
And that reminds me of hadith. The first
hadith in say Bkari where Omar may Allah
be pleased with him. He says that the
beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said
your deeds are based on your intention.
Your action are judged by intention. And
anyone who has migrated with the
intention for he has migrated for.
But if someone has migrated for the
wealth in this world or for marriage, he
has migrated for the wealth and
marriage. The intention is important.
Why did you do it? Why did you migrate?
Why did jihad? So intention is very
important for any act of worship
including psalm that is asking.